the rise of the sharing economy is
disrupting not only the way hotels and
car companies conduct their business
it's also disrupting how economists
measure us data bloomberg industries
economist Josh right joins us now with
more in a way that disrupt is a bad
thing and not a good thing well it could
be a good thing in the long run the
point here is that in the short run if
we don't change the way we measure
economic activity there could be new
forms of economic activity that the
current statistics are missing because
you think about what's going on here
with Airbnb uber you're sharing your
home you're sharing your cars you're
taking assets that were formerly purely
personal possessions and now you're
putting them to commercial use so that
means in theory we shouldn't see as much
investment in building new hotel rooms
and new taxicabs of course that's just a
first-order effect in the longer run
that should free up capacity in our
society to go and invest in other kinds
of activity and other kinds of assets
but I wonder if this changes the way we
measure GDP does that mean we're under
measuring GDP or we're over estimating
GDP well there's the potential that we
are missing some of this these capital
expenditures that are taking place in
that wedge might grow over time right
now the sharing economy is less than I
mean the entire global sharing economy
is estimated at less than point one
percent of the US economy so that's you
know a very small amount at this point
but this kind of activity is only going
to grow over time and one of the things
that's very interesting as an economist
is how this isn't a challenge for just
one industry but this model is broadly
applicable it's disrupting so many
different industries we got ride-sharing
in hotels you know most prominent but
now they're new startups is looking at
white collar jobs and they used to say
you know if you're a barber you know
your jobs safe from being out sourced
and other kinds of white collar you know
service professionals no no this is a
shared now roommates who are sharing an
apartment gonna cut each other's but is
there a positive the shared economy is
good for the average American the
consumer because now our he or she has
more money in their pocket to spend more
money this is one of the biggest
questions out there right now about how
this is going to affect economic
inequality because on the one hand
you've got people who have the
opportunity to get supplemental income
we know they're out there we know it
makes a big difference in their lives on
the other hand
you know you're taking some you can
raise for instance the rental rates
because you're taking some housing stock
off the off the market so there are
people who we know are using properties
purely through airbnb those properties
could otherwise actually be rented out
on a permanent basis to people you know
and families and communities that need
this for their everyday life not just
for tourism because you're not supposed
to use your property strictly for air
B&B right I mean isn't that a no no at
least here in New York well it's raising
all these funky questions about what
constitutes a rental property in what
constitutes an ownership property what
constitutes a contractor who is an
employee and what kinds of rights should
they have so we just had a case come
down last week from the California
Commission in California saying that
contractors for Lewbert can at least in
some cases be considered full employees
and they have to have all these benefits
and rights associated with employee
status we actually put out a whole brief
last week the bloomberg brief a special
supplement on the sharing economy and
one of the interesting questions we
explore there is the fact that we will
probably need new kinds of hybrid
categories you're not just a contractor
and you're not just an employee you're
going to need some kind of different
bundle of Rights there's recently a new
union set up by some freelancers working
for Gawker and they explored some of
these questions they said you know we
don't necessarily need you know pension
benefits or retirement benefits what we
really need is health care and really
focusing on what they need in the 21st
century except are these Millennials are
these young people who are not thinking
about their long-term future and they
should be when they're saying we don't
need to worry about that actually they
do it's just not something they're
thinking about because it's not
something they don't know yet how much
they need to worry about it although
that's always the question you know then
that you've got to have financial
education out there but we're looking at
questions of what people really need and
what kinds of arrangements they want to
have with the companies that hire all
right very cool how can i get the
bloomberg brief do i just subscribe to
the terminal you go to brief go or you
can look for it online this one we made
public because we thought it had so much
thought provoking oh very cool